au lendemain du soutien inattendu de
robert badinter à la libération de
maurice papon vont les critiques ne se
sont pas fait attendre
les propos de l'ancien garde des sceaux
ont immédiatement faire réagir les
avocats des parties civiles au procès
papon arnaud et serge klarsfeld en tête
qui ne veulent pas entendre parler de la
libération pour raisons médicales du
plus vieux prisonnier de france fabrice
turpin nouvelle polémique autour de
maurice papon hier la demande de
libération de celui qui à 90 ans le
doyen des prisonniers en france a reçu
un soutien surprenant la personne de
robert badinter l'ancien ministre de la
justice s'est prononcée au nom de la
raison humanitaire en faveur de la
libération de l'ancien haut
fonctionnaire de vichy reconnu complice
d'arrestations et de séquestration
arbitraire sous l'occupation
c'est un vieillard maintenir en prison
à 7h la main mes yeux plus de portée
et vous voyez on dit crimes contre
l'humanité je dirais ya un moment où
l'humanité doit prévaloir sur le crime
les réactions des avocats des parties
civiles qui se sont battus pendant des
années avant de voir maurice papon
comparaître devant une cour d'assises
ont été immédiates
quel serait le symbole cilso s il est
libéré maintenant ça voudrait dire que
le procès était un procès virtuel entre
gens de bonne compagnie et que
finalement après quelques mois de prison
maurice papon devrait sortir s'il est au
seuil de la mort oui il doit sortir mais
il n'est pas au seuil de la mort et les
suivis médicalement chaque jour aux à la
prison de la santé
et il faut qu'il aille au terme de sa
peine sinon l'exemplarité n'y en aurait
pas du tout je dis qu'il n'y ait pas de
légitimité à intervenir quand on a été
garde des sceaux et qu'on n'a pas levé
le petit doigt pendant un certain nombre
d'années
c'est quand on dit ben au fond un an ha
ça suffit je trouve que s'est jouée la
belle âme à peu de frais l'ancien
secrétaire général de la préfecture de
gironde sous vichy purge actuellement
une peine de dix ans de réclusion
criminelle
par deux fois déjà jacques chirac a
refusé de lui accorder la grâce
présidentielle l'avocat de maurice papon
vient donc de déposer une requête devant
la cour européenne des droits de l'homme
ils réclament à l'état plus d'un million
de francs de réparation pour traitements
inhumains et dégradants